ce que je veux suivre de près de très
près et qu'on devrait suivre de près
d'ailleurs en 2017 c'est l'attitude de
monsieur trump face à des pays qui
faisait partie du bloc soviétique à
l'époque et qui depuis la chute de
l'union soviétique se sont rapprochés de
l'otan de l'europe on parle par exemple
de l'ukraine de la pologne et des pays
baltes comme la lettonie la lituanie
l'estonie
tous ces pays donc depuis ont tenté de
se rapprocher de le temps de l'europe
face à la russie de monsieur poutine
pour monsieur poutine et bien c'est très
déplaisant tout ça parce que toujours
considéré que ces pays font partie de la
sphère d'influencé de la russie
depuis on l'a vu d'ailleurs il a annexé
la crimée s'est impliquée dans le
conflit dans l'est de l'ukraine
ce qui inquiète et donc tous les pays
que je vienne nommer ces pays là qu'ils
se sentent vraiment viser maintenant
peut-être les prochains sur la liste de
monsieur poutine
l'otan a réagi face à cette attitude de
la russie entre autres le canada va
diriger l'un contingent de 1000 hommes
qui vont être déployés en lettonie
il y en aura un peu partout dans la
région pour rassurer ces pays là ce qui
va être intéressant suivre c'est
l'attitude de monsieur trempe donc face
à ces pays et ce qui va continuer à les
rassurer face à la russie de monsieur
poutine ou est-ce que son amitié sa
prétendue amitié avec monsieur poutine
va le pousser à reconnaître que ces pays
font bel et bien partie de la sphère
d'influencé de la russie
ce sera à suivre et savent en dire long
[Musique]